foreign
looking back at what the decade has
given us anime fans over the past few
years is just a mood that I've been
getting into over the past few videos
isn't it we're only three years into the
decade but we've already got a lot of
memories to remember down the line for
now let's continue appreciating more the
best of anime three years in and we've
already got a lot of Epic sword fights
so that's what we're going with today
let's see what anime has given us in the
past three years as far as the other
popular weapons concerned we start
things off not with a Japanese product
but a Chinese anime fog heels gave us an
amazing example of swordsmanship in its
Bridge fight
all right
fog Hills is just a show that's always
amazed me the plot's short and simple
and when I look at it it doesn't exactly
knock anything out of the park with its
narrative still it does decently enough
for itself as a story however when the
spotlight turns to the fight scenes in
the animation it's a whole different
story seeing the flurry of the sword
fight never fails to bring me joy to
think that it's a niche anime from a
place that's not exactly known for
exporting animation it just amazes me
how smooth and frantic the Motions in
this sequence are fog Hills doesn't have
a lot of episodes but each episode
counts with moments like this whether it
be this fight or one of the many other
action sequences featured on this
channel before have got nothing but
respect for the guys who brought us this
show
[Music]
[__]
you like the recently concluded full
season of Don Machi well let's rewind
time a bit and take a look at season
three
thank you
Bill vs asterius from the third season
for me is one of the best fights
dynamachi had to offer throughout its
run they had a previous fight but this
one was just something else it's one of
the fights that started out red hot and
got even better the more the fighters
wore each other down it's also hard not
to cheer for asterius as the battle
progressed with the latter digging deep
to overcome Bale's head-on attack
there's also some symbolic thing going
on there with asterius destroying the
red Minotaur knife Bell had making this
feel like a rite of passage for him and
an establishing moment for his role as
Belle's rival when it's all said and
done we had one winner and things have
finally evened out for the two of them
the words now we're even run a lot
deeper than the surface when you think
about it it's not just about their
record against each other but also how
each of them contributed in making the
other stronger through their victories
in battle
foreign
before we continue let me ask you a
question have you ever wondered what
it's like being in Japan but don't have
the budget to take that long flight
there but with our sponsors Tokyo tree
and sakurako you can get a glimpse of
what Japan tastes like Tokyo tree and
sakurako are subscription-based snack
boxes that both aim to provide the
authentic Japan experience right on your
doorstep Tokyo tree delves more on the
cooler seasonal and limited edition
snacks with sakurako however you'll find
a lot of authentic and Artisan snacks
that give you a very genuine feel of
what Japan has to offer through its
various regions and prefectures to cap
it all off you typically get some Nifty
kitchenware to go with it too and every
box includes a booklet with information
about all of the snacks including
allergen information and Japanese
culture and this month Tokyo treat takes
you to the always energetic city of
Osaka this month's box shows you why
many people consider Osaka The Culinary
capital of Japan I personally love this
chocolate orange KitKat but you also
don't want to miss the Lifeguard soft
candy that they'll be giving out this
time sakurako on the other hand wants
you to enjoy Japan's fruit Marvels and
mochi two deserves that Japan is famous
for there's no better way to get a taste
of them through this month's sakurako
box sounds like a good deal doesn't it
right that's why I'm inviting you to try
subscribing to Tokyo tree and sakurako
snack boxes through the link in the
description here's your once in a
lifetime chance to experience all of
Japan's best offerings right in the
comfort of your own home godana man
versus Genji is a great finale for the
first part of Chainsaw man
Katana man and denji had quite a
confrontation back in episode 9. in that
dance you got routinely rooted and it's
a shining moment that truly sold us all
on how much of a tough opponent Katana
man is their second battle I feel
manages to surpass the first one even
with all the expectations built upon
that tense encounter after some failed
attempts at diplomacy we got the usual
chainsaw man goodness with the big loud
fighting that sends both combatants
flying through the city Katana man
hasn't lost the steps since the previous
battle and he puts denji in an arguably
worse State than he was in their fight
with arms cut off Dengue was completely
helpless against the Unstoppable force
in front of him also everyone thought I
really like comeback wins like this you
know even at such a disadvantage denji
manages to sneak out a whim I didn't see
the leg chainsaw coming and it's all it
took for the winner to be decided this
time round Fortune flips at the
slightest touch
[Music]
fish
Erman
following chainsaw man we have another
Super hype show but this time from a
decade ago it's Sword Art Online
[Music]
foreign
's favorite son ever since becoming a
Smash Hit over 10 years ago as such it's
gotten a lot of love over the years and
it's the franchise that we consistently
get content one after another in a new
decade it doesn't nearly have as much of
a foothold in the popularity side of
things anymore but A1 orbit stepped up
their game in terms of animating it just
look at the fights in War of Underworld
the animation for the fights reach
all-time highs for the franchise and
with the help of amazing music and Voice
work they elevated some of the biggest
fights in the series like vector versus
bur Coley the thing is in terms of the
actual fight itself it's not even that
spectacular but only despite being the
strongest Integrity Knight was
completely outmatched and had to resort
to stalling to charge up his op skill
it's a one-sided Affair that looked a
lot more intense thanks to the efforts
of the anime team you can tell that
everyone put their heart into this one
especially those last moments that makes
this fight a winner in my book
foreign
bleach made a Triumph from return and
it's on the heels of absolutely
spectacular fight kenbachi vs unohana is
one of those
long time bleach fans know how little
the pre-blood war Arc said unohana in
action for supposedly being one of the
senior captains should get so little
time out in the battlefield when she
draws her sword as this new season
showed she's a monster more than capable
of standing up to Kenpachi himself
unohana and Kenpachi had their fight in
the only place capable of holding their
insane bloodlust and thirst for battle
it truly is the unohana fight long time
bleach fans wanted and finally got and
it's one of the first times we truly see
kenpanchi getting pushed to the edge
this was a death match for the ages and
the anime team really brought out the
best of it with the overall direction of
the scene seeing unohana's Bankai and
having it elaborated on more than what
the manga readers got truly was the
cherry on top
holding on
[Music]
utsuro vs gintoki is a fitting finale to
a Godly series
I love serious skin time I really do
especially when they give us epic
clashes like in Toki versus dirocho and
The Showdown against takasugi it's all
fitting that we got something as good as
this for the finale and what makes this
battle so good it's not even the actual
fighting Gintama while having some
fights that look so good it's a show
whose fights are built through dialogue
emotions and build up that's not to say
that UFO table or mapper fights are
lacking in Emotion but the whole
methodical approach is obviously more
emphasized in a story that's gone on for
a long while and has so many arcs of
building like in Tama this final battle
is relatively quiet both figuratively
and literally and it made for such a
captivating Showdown longtime fans also
get a treat to see old fights
Incorporated in this final battle
reminding everyone of the journey we've
all been through it's the finale that we
all deserve
rounding out the list is tengen versus
gyotaro foreign
of course we can't leave out one of the
best fights we got in Demon Slayers
anime adaptation 10 gen versus gyotaro
is what you'd expect from a series that
exploded into popularity on the wake of
absolutely stunning fight animation I
normally include the whole sequence when
talking about this fight since it lasted
for half the arc basically but when
viewing the last stretch that heavily
featured 10 getting gyotaro it's still
an amazing battle true it's a segment
that's largely carried by the context by
the effort and the journey to get to
this point of being so close to
defeating an upper moon but seeing
tengen clash with gyotaro and him using
his creativity to find a way to overcome
the demon Lord's bloodblades was still
something to behold and who could forget
the insane Clash of blades they had as
well kudos to the anime team for yet
another amazing Showdown something we've
all come to expect as the norm for Demon
Slayer
thank you
[Applause]
we move on with a one-piece fight
featuring Zorro and King
thank you
Zorro's been in some of modern one
piece's best fights these three years
have really done a lot to solidify this
swordsman as one of my favorite
characters in the show and the fight
with King is no exception the one I want
gave him more of an opportunity to shine
with a prime time Showdown against King
someone who's just as much of a master
of the sword as he is King and Zorro's
back and forth is a thing of beauty as
is the way they executed their game
plans on one another in the course of
their grueling jewel in the end it was
Zorro's willpower that proved to be the
decider his aspirations gave him that
one extra push to emerge victorious in
this encounter and watching it all
unfold and manifest was nothing short of
satisfying
thank you
[Music]
and those are my favorite sword fights
from 2020 to 2023 hope you enjoyed this
video and if you've got any feedback
then don't forget to drop by the comment
section you can also follow Vinnie tube
on social media with links provided in
the description box that's it for today
hope to catch you in the next video see
you next time